I wanted her to make it I did that's
Jane Fonda opening up about Megyn
Kelly's fall from grace because you do
get in trouble if you are a white person
who puts on black Halloween or a black
person who puts on white face for
Halloween like back when I was a kid
that was okay as long as you were
dressing there's like a character eats
he caught up with Jane on the red carpet
at the Women's Media Center Awards in
New York where she opened up about
Megan's controversial comments regarding
blackface on Halloween I wanted her to
make it I did that's always how everyone
learns is through making mistakes you
know it's it's we fail yer that we grow
and learn I know that's been true for me
and I think it is for everybody yeah the
80 year old actress also got candid
about what it means to have women at the
forefront of media today we've got to
have women telling the stories we've got
to have women interpreting what's
happening a lot of what's happening is
against women and we want to see them
you know women have a we experience and
understand things differently than men
not necessarily better or worse just
differently and if if our narrative is
untold from our point of view then
and women are robbed of half of the
narrative getting parody for women in
front of the camera behind the camera
writing the op-ed pieces on a parody
with men being the on-air experts on a
parody with men those Sunday talk shows
are still way too men and we just it's
different when we tell it and you know
you understand it from a different
perspective it being everything that
we're facing and why it's more important
is because what we're facing is really
scary and crucial and we got to solve it
I think women are gonna have to lead the
way I really do
then found a dish on how she's ready for
a nine-to-five reboot I'm waiting for
the new script
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]